hello and welcome the video in the
play-off some and high queens of
cambodia if the monsters but
the family before here before jakob i think
before you are starting with the
objective of change a thing
to 6
right moves like jagger
the serbian president willi wanted with
a good tactic with the doppik
services hosting and the whistle surgery
helping black pearl agency discovery
play off to improve their positions
[music]
the overall profile absolutely regretted
holding too much media camp let s get
enough is ok so the new action replay
has traded so cleverly  sf6
it's the check on progressive
open
hmm they're doing so laboriously north an happy about
and now what
the five with be ok
[music]
it's supposed to be the sixties sound you'll do that
first and check architecture bishop
irinej streetwork okay maybe
institute in  jackson and institute
in tegel is with 55 cents per minute that
is is god cars patient cognition is
fast topless see and the if
d  u afraid
here is jack possibly let's get right
here is not getting the queen checks
here
keystone the fictional tv movie tv
[music]
answer left the village and get is back
not so much more than some way that
looked the least pollicino
[laughter]
katharina  frie s not raid teams four
leaves had to intercity in the
capturing that is supplied in any way meadow there
it is the 5 and winners bed
he is it still good kay one is much
better have to go go thinks servicegame